[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to we're
all familiar with the show Family Guy
either fondly okay that is the last time
you were gonna pull that crap not so
fondly or seasons one through six
finally enough there's something you may
not have known before the long-running
series well briefly short running series
then long-running series I know nothing
about that Cartoon Network ran a short
in 1997 you may find a little familiar
Larry it's us here your licenses to
spread the bond on a they day you still
awake temporarily yep
that's Seth MacFarlane doing an eerily
similar Brian the dog as well as an
eerily similar Peter Griffin only here
they're not called Brian and Peter
they're called Larry and Steve and yes
this was played on Cartoon Network
during the day not during Adult Swim
this was meant for kids it was part
Cartoon Network experimenting with
cartoon pilots on a section they called
what a cartoon which resulted in several
popular shows being made so was the
original idea for Family Guy supposed to
be a kid show it certainly seems that
way the seven minutes short begins with
Steve talking to a camera explaining his
situation that being stuck with Larry hi
there my name is Steve I'm a dog and in
case your rope well stupid apparently he
was at the pound and out of all the
humans Larry was the only one who could
understand them this is hilariously
never explained as everyone else just
here's embarked it's just kinda how this
world works you would be indirectly
responsible for the resulting euthanasia
boy they got enough kids or whatever it
is Steve of course is an intelligent
cynic and Larry is a brainless doofus
and somehow they have to survive mundane
adventures like getting a new lamp with
Larry however that proves difficult as
he's constantly getting them into
trouble
how do you feel Steve like Agamemnon
after the fury of Clytemnestra kind of
Inspector Gadget and brain going to the
grocery store he's always gotta savor
the humor isn't hilarious but it's not
bad either it has a lot of slapstick
cartoony jokes as well as a good line
here and there I think I know what I'm
talking about all right all right I
didn't spend 12 years in kindergarten
because I'm stupid
it even has bits of surreal humor
similar to a Family Guy would eventually
incorporate just ask our spokesman
Nikita xenophobic Scotsman what's
especially funny is all the
foreshadowing to the Family Guy show
that ends up here for example the names
of one of the stores they're looking for
is Stewie's which would eventually be
Peters son in the show Stewie's is
usually got good stuff this guy looks
pretty close to Peter's dead either
better let's just hope it's not him
Steve's design you can certainly see
elements of Brian in and Larry though
seemingly different in layout actually
is very similar just trim down the nose
change the hair it's surprisingly really
close overall it's a cute little short
and honestly might have been a decent
kid show maybe even along the lines of
Johnny Bravo Dexter's Lab and so on
however while those shows were picked up
sets wasn't the net were passed on the
show but let's s style so much that they
brought him on to be a writer on some of
the shows that did get picked up he
would try again on another show though
call zoo mates another pilot but this
time for Nickelodeon and this time with
the help of Butch Hartman who will go on
to develop hits like Fairly OddParents
and Danny Phantom
it was odd but for different reasons his
other shows are odd it was just animals
trying to live together in an apartment
but messing things up standard enough
but there was a laugh track over the
entire show I'm gonna bust your head
when I'm finished No
to this day I have no idea if this was
done ironically or in the same spirit as
the Flintstones where we're supposed to
believe somehow an audience is laughing
at this
[Music]
no surprise this one was not picked up
however executives from Fox saw Larry
and Steve and we're interest in Seth
creating a show based on the concept
except with an adult edge this is
naturally where Family Guy came from so
there it is Family Guy was originally
meant for kids right there's another
part of the story you see well let the
Rhode Island School for Design Seth had
to put together a thesis film in 1995 he
starred himself introducing his animated
characters living in in everyday
suburban home embarking on surreal
adventures with cutaways the name of
that thesis the life of Larry which once
again stars a doofus named Larry and his
talking cynical dog named Steve yeah I
think what happened is he eats his food
and then whatever Spock can't finish
where where did you where did you hear
that episode 65 huh and when you know it
he also has a patient wife named Lois
fine what's habitation for the
10-million v Larry an overweight son
named melt and Steph Chris and a much
more adult tone in fact many of these
jokes would eventually make its way into
the Family Guy pilot which would
eventually make its way into the Family
Guy show it's actually kind of eerie how
similar these jokes are in every
incarnation
I got it that's the guy from fake Tom
Hanks that's it off funny guy everything
he says is a stitch I have AIDS
so when Fox saw this was also part of
the Larry and Steve portfolio they said
that match their animation outline
perfect although maybe not perfect
enough it was decided they should fatten
up their lead and give them a baby add a
geeky daughter and focus more on the
family dynamic hence the title Family
Guy looking all too familiar to another
animated Fox family so there's kind of a
lot to be discovered here isn't there
was Family Guy originally meant to be a
kid show for a short amount of time
originally it was an adult comedy film
thesis about a guy and his dog which
turned into a kid show pilot about a guy
and his dog which turned into an adult
show pilot that was made to be more like
the Simpsons because it was on Fox so
not only was it at one point a kid show
it actually had little to no tie-in with
the simpsons at all which is a criticism
the show's had to fight for years even
in the sentence Family Guy crossover
they referenced it and the Simpsons took
more than their fair
share of punches ever it's just a lousy
ripple it may have been inspired by Duff
but I like to think it goes in a
different direction well it's pretty
obvious where that later influence came
from for Family Guy you can see the
original idea has no connection so the
evolution of an idea isn't always as
simple as you think actually many times
it's very complicated from an adult show
to a kids show to an all-too-familiar
Fox formula this idea has gone through
so many versions but truth be told all
of them are interesting to check out if
you can find them obvious you can tell
from the quality here they're not the
easiest to locate there certainly we're
viewing to witness the creative process
where the illah family guy hate it used
to love it or used to hate it there's no
denying the constant changing ways and
ideas formed is intriguing to watch
but seriously that hurt me joke has to
stop I'm not nostalgia critic I remember
it so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hello dog walker here and a special
hello to all the YouTube comments
wondering where the review is thank you
for watching till the end
pretty much I'm out of town I'm at a con
and I am also on a vacation taking a
short vacation but I didn't want to
leave you guys with nothing so I did a
facile editorial here but the reviews
will go right back up next week so we'll
be right back on track a review an
editorial review editorial so on so
forth
so yeah either way I hope you guys enjoy
watching and I'll see you next week for
the review and here's me shot a week ago
doing the charity shout out hey Doug
Walker here doing the charity shout out
and this week we are doing the Marine
Mammal Center these people are guided
and inspired by a shared vision of a
healthy ocean for marine mammals and
humans alike their mission is to advance
global ocean conservation to marine
mammal rescue and rehabilitation as well
as scientific research and education
since 1975 they have rescued and treated
nearly 20,000 marine animals they've
rescue marine mammals for different
reasons including malnourished
separation entanglements and diseases
they've recognized the fundamental
relationship that binds humans animals
and the ocean they also partner with
leading scientists and other
professionals in order to learn from the
patients in their care patients from
healthy endangered and at-risk
populations to expand and advise
scientific knowledge enhancing
understanding of the health of our
oceans and the implications for human
health they spread knowledge to members
of the scientific community and general
public of what they find out if you look
at their site in their YouTube page you
can see not only all the amazing
discoveries they've come across but also
all the remarkable creatures they save
look at these guys how can you say no to
them
you can show you care by looking at
their site and helping the oceans stay
amazing for years to come
take a click and take a look
you
[Music]